dans combien de province et territoire
trouve-t-on le cerf de virginie neuf
provinces et deux territoires ce cervidé
est présent partout au canada sauf à
terre neuve et labrador et au nunavut au
sud du pays son aire de répartition va
du cap breton à l'est jusqu'au milieu de
la colombie-britannique à l'ouest dans
le nord du pays le cerf de virginie à
remonter jusqu à dawson city au yukon et
au grand lac des esclaves dans les
territoires du nord-ouest
cette répartition du cerf de virginie
est assez récente les premiers européens
débarquer sur le territoire ont parfois
aperçu le ruminant mais dans l'extrême
sud du pays seulement puis au moment de
la confédération en 1867
on remarque que le cerf de virginie se
multiplient rapidement dans le sud du
québec le long du fleuve saint laurent
bientôt ils peuplent les abords de la
rivière des outaouais et de rares bête
s'aventure même au sud du manitoba à
cette période il est parfois visibles au
nouveau brunswick mais jamais en
nouvelle écosse aujourd'hui le cerf de
virginie est le plus répandu de tous les
grands animaux d'amérique du nord il vit
même dans l'archipel français de saint
pierre et miquelon au sud du golfe du
saint laurent mais dans ces îles comme à
anticosti il a été introduit